Oh
this is a collaboration with all-time
conspiracies make sure to follow the
link at the end of this video to check
out theirs if you look around YouTube
you'll find plenty of videos claiming
that the moon landings were faked or
that NASA has been lying to us or that
the earth is flat and while these
opinions are largely considered to be a
little bit crazy they do offer a chance
to think about the repercussions if such
a scenario was actually the case what if
we really never went to the moon to
understand why we wouldn't have gone to
the moon we first need to understand why
we did back in the 1950s and 60s the
United States and the Soviet Union had
to put it lightly less than friendly
opinions of one another as two global
superpowers the US and the USSR were
constantly locked in a state of
one-upsmanship trying to outdo the
others achievements so it should come as
no surprise that when the Soviet Union
successfully launched Sputnik into space
making it the first artificial satellite
in orbit the United States felt the need
to retaliate in a big way the u.s.
dumped huge sums of money into
researching and funding new technology
and science to find some way to outshine
the USSR from this frenzy drive to
compete sprung a fully fledged American
space program which eventually landed
two men on the moon in 1969 so really we
have the Soviet Union to thank for NASA
with that in mind if the USSR hadn't
spent so much time and money on their
space program perhaps the United States
wouldn't have felt the need to develop
their own instead choosing to focus on
more traditional ways of beating their
enemies like big guns and bigger bombs
if the United States chose not to pursue
the space program the world today would
be a very different place as of 2017
it's estimated that for every $1 spent
on NASA funding the US economy grows by
ten dollars through commercial use of
NASA developed technology what happens
if that all goes away let's go back in
time to the heat of the space race
perhaps the cornerstone of the US
response to Sputnik was former President
Eisenhower's National Defense Education
Act which poured massive sums of money
into the u.s. education system as the
1950s drew to a close and the 60s began
PhD intake at American universities
nearly tripled especially in scientific
fields like
six all in preparation for the graduates
to provide new brainpower for the Apollo
program while NASA was trying to figure
out how to put a man on the moon they
determined that there was a very real
need for smaller computers to use in
their spacecraft as computers in those
days often took up entire rooms when a
company called Fairchild Semiconductor
began experimenting with a new invention
called the integrated circuit the
predecessor of the microchip NASA
ordered a million of them to kick-start
the fledgling industry without the space
race we might not have developed the
microchip for many more years and to go
a step further to employees from
Fairchild would later found a little
company called
Intel the very Intel that makes the chip
inside my computer that makes this video
possible besides shrinking the footprint
required for NASA's spacecraft computers
electronic micro components led to the
personal computer the laptop and early
handheld devices perhaps more important
than the technological boost the space
race gave the public is the inspiration
and mindset the Apollo program gave
students and children growing up and
graduating through the 60s and 70s Bob
Richards space entrepreneur and
co-founder of Moon Express was one such
student and founded the global group
students for the exploration and
development of space in 1980 this group
was headed for a year by none other than
Jeff Bezos who was inspired by the
Apollo program and later pursued his own
lofty goals and founded Amazon that's a
bizarre thought without the space race
we might not have Amazon and not only
Amazon we might not have SpaceX or
Virgin Galactic or even Silicon Valley
which was essentially born out of the
necessity of the Apollo program and the
development of the integrated circuit
the technological trickle down from the
space race was world-changing former
NASA flight director Glynn Lunney
witnessed this dramatic shift and says
Apollo really did Drive our industry we
were asking people to do things that
were probably 10 or 20 years faster than
they otherwise would have done and they
knew it they stepped up to it and
succeeded today's cell phones wireless
equipment
iPads and so on are a result of the fact
that the country did this high-tech
thing and created this large portfolio
of available technologies think about
that for a moment consider how your life
would be different if technology today
was 20 years behind
is now for starters you'd be using a
Dell IBM or HP tower computer the iMac
wouldn't hit the scene for another year
you'd communicate with friends using AOL
Instant Messenger and hear this sound a
lot
[Music]
[Music]
say goodbye to Google search you'd
likely be using Yahoo or if you're on
the cutting edge Ask Jeeves you probably
wouldn't even be using the now hated
internet explorer yet you'd be browsing
the very primitive web with Netscape
Navigator your nice 4k screen would be
gone replaced with a 20 pound 640 by 480
resolution CRT monitor gone are all your
favorite games no more minecraft
battlegrounds call of duty or halo but
at least you have quake 2 if you wanted
to take your music with you on the go
you could spend $1,000 on a CD burner
clip on a sweet portable CD player and
be the coolest guy on the block like
taking photos you'd likely still be
using film but if you really wanted a
digital camera you could go for the new
Fuji film D s7 with a stunning
resolution of 0.3 megapixels and of
course we can't forget the most
important item of all your phone with 20
year old technology you've got a couple
of options
the Nokia 6110 or the super cutting-edge
Motorola StarTAC
the world's first flip phone the StarTAC
would give you a whole 60 minutes of
talk time for a reasonable $1000 and
that's all just the tip of the iceberg
the space race spurred so many
advancements in almost all areas of life
including military productivity
navigation and communication all of
which we take for granted today both as
a country and as individuals needless to
say the world would be a very different
place had we not decided to land humans
on the moon how far behind would we be
today it's hard to say but it's clear
that the innovation of the Apollo era
laid the groundwork for all the
technological marvels we see in our
daily life and around the
world when you think about it in terms
of individual items it's amazing to
think what we would have missed out on
had we not gone to the moon and with
that in mind who knows what we could
achieve with another lofty goal in space
remember the conspiracies I mentioned at
the beginning of this video one of the
most popular is the thought that maybe
famous director Stanley Kubrick faked
the moon landings want to learn more
check out this video by all time
conspiracies you can watch my other
space related videos by clicking here or
for something completely different you
can click here to watch me play games
with a friend on my new gaming channel
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video